good morning how are you that's good
we've been hearing from people all over
the country and the last since last
night and this morning seems like people
have a spring in their step because the
president was held accountable for his
reckless behavior no one is above the
law and the Constitution is the supreme
law of the land no one is above the law
and the president has been held
accountable it really is interesting to
see the response that we are getting
bipartisan across party lines
I myself want to say I have a spring in
my step because of the moral courage of
our caucus to see them all so many of a
hundred numbers go to the floor and sold
we had time for to go to the floor and
speak about our Constitution about the
facts of the case so clearly so
patriotically so prayerfully I said
solemnly but so definitely I have just
to get this off the table right away
when teach the president immediately
everybody was going to the next thing
the next thing for us will be when we
see the process that is set forth in the
Senate then we'll know the number of
monitors that we may have to go forward
and who that with who we would choose
that's what I said last night that's
what I'm saying now I'd be a precedent
for this and I met with my six chairs
after some of us were together for a
press conference after the votes last
night and we discussed the precedent of
it all and that is in the most recent
case
taking up an impeachment there was a
proposal on the floor put together by in
a bipartisan way 100 senators voted for
the process on how they would go forward
on the case of President Clinton we
would hope that they could come to some
conclusion like that but in any event
we're ready when we see what they have
we'll know who and how many we will send
over that's all I'm going to say about
that now we've had a very eventful week
I'm so proud of our members and they
really in some cases of bipartisanship
of some of this and some not last year's
campaign we said for the people we would
lower the cost of health care
starting with lowering the cost of
prescription drugs and preserving the
pre-existing condition benefit but in
the past week we passed the Elijah
Cummings lower drug cost now Act which
does just for that as we were passing it
last week we discussed the particulars
of it but with the savings that we
gained from that I think it's important
to note that we already said we would be
spending the hundreds of billions of
dollars in savings on expanding benefits
for Medicare dental visual hearing and
then the most the biggest expansion of
net F of Medicare since its inception
next we did we did lower vas important
bipartisan bill the appropriations bill
to keep government open and to do so
early enough so that you knew to make
your weekend plans and get started for
all the holidays you may be observing
and that was a major accomplishment took
constant back-and-forth but we ended up
with as I've always said as an
appropriate or myself one fortune in
that culture left to their own devices
the appropriators can get the job done
and I salute chairwoman need Aloe way
for her work the ranking member as well
and we're very pleased with with that
legislation I guess I would take up
cloture or something on the Senate
pretty soon hopefully it will be on its
way to the president for a signature
before I leave the subject of
impeachment so let me commend our six
chairman Adam Schiff Adam Schiff Jerry
Nadler chair of judiciary so proud of
him Maxine Waters Financial Services
Ritchie Neal but Ways and Means
Committee eliot engel the Foreign
Affairs Committee and also a very
important committee chair now by carolyn
maloney the government form committee I
said last night and I say today while he
isn't with us today in physically here
Elijah Cummings is with us in spirit a
foundation he helped laid for justice is
with us and and he said when we're
dancing with the Angels
what will we know about what we did to
keep the Constitution intact when he
said that it was very prescient little
did we know that by the time we passed
the impeachment resolution above the
articles of impeachment that he would be
dancing with the Angels right now as we
speak debating on the floor of the US
Mexico Canada trade agreement I hear my
colleagues on the floor last night
saying well off we were doing this we
could do Mexico but we are doing Mexico
and the discussion that took some time
to convince the administration and the
other countries was that we weren't
going forward until we had the strongest
possible enforcement of the other of the
legislate of the trade agreement as and
also manifested in the legislation that
we'll have on the floor today the
implementing legislation as you've heard
me say over and over again this is about
enforcement the overarching issue if you
can't enforce it it doesn't matter what
you put forth and other concerns that we
had one were workers workers rights the
other pharmaceuticals and the other the
environment and we make giant progress
from first of all over the existing
NAFTA for sure but apart from that
the distance between what the
administration was proposing to begin
with in all of those areas and to where
we ended up now going forward I am very
pleased to have the statement today that
went out from the afl-cio from Richard
Trumka said we are proud he said there
is no denying that the trade rules in
America will now be fair working people
have created a new standard for future
trade negotiations I think it's a
template for future trade agreements
some of my members think let's not give
it that much but we'll see how it goes
in the implementation and that means
everything then after that today we will
do salt and that is going to be this on
the state and local tax that the
Republicans put on to punish blue states
largely the that is paid for this
legislation to repeal the salt tax and
it will be paid for by increasing the
rate on wealthiest individuals in our
country when the president first
proposed his tax scam they were saying
we're never going to lower the
individual rate and then they did and
now we will raise it again to repeal the
salt so there we're very proud of what
we have done as you know the Republicans
keep saying we always should be working
you know we sent over 400 bills 275 of
them sitting on Mitch McConnell's debt
were 400 but 275 of those at least are
bipartisan the range of subjects is well
you've heard me say it but it bears
repeating I think that includes all of
our top ten pieces of legislation
bipartisan background checks expanding
background checks people have to have a
background check unless they buy it at a
gun show online
or in some kind of stroll straw
transaction so this is not creating
background checks it is expanding and as
well as the South Carolina but one is HR
8 the other
11:12 295 days ago we sent those bills
to Mitch McConnell the Grim Reaper I've
news for him he may think they're dead
on arrival there but they are alive and
well in the general public and every day
that he does not take up that
legislation because he knows it will
pass he fears that it will pass or else
he'd take it up every day that he does
not pass it 100 people died not all of
them would by gun violence not all of
them would be saved by the legislation
but some and so we urge him to take up
that life-saving legislation the list
goes on Paycheck Fairness equal pay for
equal work Violence Against Women Act
again about women the legislation to
raise the minimum wage of the 30-some
million 30 to 33 million people who will
get a pay raise with the increase in the
minimum wage over 20 million of them are
women equality acted and discrimination
against the LGBTQ community dream and
promise act a safe act save our Federal
Elections Act butch Lewis Act protecting
pensions for America's workers farm
workforce Modernization Act which we
passed the other day it was bipartisan
support and has bipartisan support
inside and outside the Congress again
lower drug cost now one of the bill that
we did pass it I we had an enrollment
ceremony perhaps someone who came was
the futures the future future act and
that was about minority serving
institutions Hispanic serving
institutions historical black colleges
and universities universe higher
education institutions that deal with
our Native American population it's very
important we sent it that did pass and
that is on its way to them to the
president so with that we said to my
members what I say to you guys all the
time the word recreative recreate are
the same words I had they spelled the
same and they mean something the same
you recreate renew rest I'll be with
your family you are recreated to come
back for the discussions in their base
ahead as we go into the future and if we
go into the future again we are inspired
by our founders who said ich liebe
assumed unum
from anyone from anyone no matter what
our differences and they certainly had
theirs we always have to remember that
we are one country I have my speakers
pin on today but many times I have on
the flag pin which said one country one
destiny we have to think in those terms
and we look forward to doing that
after the well as we go forward we still
have a day here as we go forward so I
wish you happy holidays and whatever you
are celebrating in our house we
celebrate them all Christmas Hanukkah
Kwanzaa New Year's whatever else but I
hope you have it now have time for a few
questions
do you run the risk as demo and start
that again do you run the risk of some
Republicans have said of looking like
you're playing games with impeachment if
you hold on to these articles or too
long I said what I was gonna say Nancy
we are we have I have when we bring the
bill which is just so you know there's a
bill may be wanted by the news committee
that we can call up at any time in order
to send it over to the Senate and to
have them provisionary pay for their for
the presentation and then the next step
is the kept up whatever you want to call
it the trial
that is where you put the managers I was
not prepared to put the managers and
that deal yet because we don't know the
arena that we were in it frankly I don't
care what any public say I said this is
it
we'd like to see a fair process but
we'll see what they have and we'll be
ready for whatever it is you guys the
ones that require me want you to see a
fair process before we would hope there
would be a fair process just as we hope
that they would honor the Constitution
by the way I saw some of it and see it
but I heard some of what Mitch McConnell
said today and it reminded me that our
founders and when they wrote the
Constitution they suspected that there
could be a roast president I don't think
they suspected that we could have a
rogue president and a rogue leader in
the Senate at the same time any other
questions or any Azote I were told of
Mexico free trade agreement advisory
about that jobs the American people's
progress and addressing both ilysm and
the issues anybody were talking about
the context that we're passing today
important issues that relate to the
economic vitality of our communities and
the other person because I'm not going
to answer any more questions on this
Peter clearly do understand when we see
what their process is we will know who
and how many we want to send over this
course was not until then I'm not going
to go there anymore yes
of course we'll take credit for it
because what he proposed not filled the
bill with what he just is fine but here
are those and some of you have been care
about substance we have in the past
asked about whether we would pass that
because it would be have what we call
collateral benefit to the president I
don't care about that but we had we had
an opportunity to do something very
important for the American people for
America's workers and we could not let
any stand in the way of that because he
would go out and take credit so this is
this isn't about him it's about American
workers it's about being good neighbors
in our hemisphere and frankly we weren't
going to go down that path until the
administration conceded on many of the
provisions that they had in the original
proposal which were not acceptable
and which were not as you described the
president would describe the president
that's it doesn't last night had some
pretty harsh comments about your dear
friend Debbie Dingell and her late
husband wondering if you had any
reaction let us pray I was praying for
the president this is the president
clearly was insecure when it comes to
States persons whether it was John
McCain thankful what he said about John
McCain and his supporters over walked
back
now john dingell but the present on this
understands is that cruelty is not
whipped just because he gets a last was
saying the cool things that he says
doesn't mean he's funny it's not funny
at all it's very sad
thank you all very much happy holiday